[Music]
everybody leave my family out of these
next few articles my dad doesn't have a
butt hey it's on patreon we're good
that's where i mostly talk about my
family
on patreon patreon my dad likes to wear
these bandana pretty short stuff he's
like a cholo shit's tight dude are they
comfortable i don't know he's cripping
dude his dad is straight cripping
i don't know why he got those either
they're like paisley yeah
shorts he has like three pairs of them
that's fresh blue bandanna print he
might get [ __ ] banged on or something
but i don't know
i think he's og
he's like genuinely fresh blue bandanna
print shorts stretch stretched out
undershirt that's a v-neck
that stretched the [ __ ] out because you
can tell it's 10 years old and he tucks
it in yeah that's fire with crusty feet
and sandals is my dad and a rolex that's
my dad's uh
wardrobe that was a lot of swag paisley
bandana shorts and a rolex is like a lot
then a stretch
vintage
20-year hangs [ __ ] undershirt your
dad probably crushes dude crushes what
puss dude
he's seen him crush bliss he knows
we can confirm
bury his face on a girl's crotch you've
seen him eat box dude
where what i used to be roommates with
his dad
went downstairs that's what was [ __ ]
motorboating his girlfriend's puss you
put a sock on the door and everything
right it was crazy and the chick was
liking it too i heard i heard he was
good clothes on yeah
my dad's over the pants
too he told me he was that girlfriend he
was like he's like hey you know i've
been thinking about the end of my life
and he goes i don't think i want to go
alone so i'm going to find a partner i'm
like that's cool
all right so if you're out there
watching and you guys want [ __ ] is
that bart's dad
between the ages of 60 and 70
you're looking for a hot dude with
crippen shorts
griffin shorts
and dm part for details fans are not
safe any elderly highness
or not
or all ages with a loud voice because
you can't hear above 18. get them up
yeah you must have a loud voice i'm not
sure where we started but i like where
we go
[ __ ] the article dude let's look bart's
dad up yeah honestly that that should be
a huge thing which we should actually
[ __ ] make like a tinder account for
him or something dude just start swiping
over oh yeah a little bumble so we can
use your dad's hope of not dying alone
is personal entertainment
that's i mean monetize bro content i'd
be laughing all day dude
i just honestly think that would be
wonderful right just like
a great yeah well maybe tinder is like
not the other people on tinder his age
yeah do they even not use tinder dude
they're all over the place man man
there's [ __ ] i saw this weightlifting
grandma and her
daughter that looks like a grandma on
tinder no on um
instagram they were [ __ ] buff and i
was like what the [ __ ] so confusing man
how you got a body of a 40 year old and
you're like
goddamn 80. i bet you i bet you there's
like a tinder for old people yeah watch
i'm going to google tinder for old
people it's called senior christian
farmers only for sure close to the end
close to the edge
that's good that's a good dating app
yeah if that's not made already you
should
hey dating sites for adults 50 plus
number one our time hour
time that's good it's dark as the finish
line
finish live
jesus christ that's two on the nose
finish last two cross alone [ __ ]
curtain call
dead lights out lights out death bed
death bed
that's two out of those that's two the
leftovers crazy
crazy i asked my dad i was like when you
do go on these dates like what's the
typical questions you ask or
conversation just to hear like what it
goes like when you're my age you don't
deal with [ __ ] so you go do you have
any debt and then like do you own a
house because he owns his own house so
he doesn't want a leech so he wants it
where it's like they also own their own
house and they make it a decision
whose house they live in rather than a
default i just move in with you wow so i
was like damn these are some like just
that's true because when you're like 70
and you're like
man you had a lot of time to get your
[ __ ] together and you're still a [ __ ]
loser yeah because no wonder you're
single that's what i don't like women
like hey like can you get your dick hard
oh yeah probably like that too and you
know how in bubble they ask you like
what's your favorite tv show to watch
like they have all these prompts for old
people dating apps they should be like
do you have that just can you get your
dick hard like there should be those
questions do you got cancer
he has no problem because he has that
chinese moonshine he makes back to his
couch yeah he has like this [ __ ] that
makes that give him a boner hennessy
filled with ginseng and [ __ ] dates
and [ __ ]
when he drinks that he's ready to go
how long does it take does he say it i
don't know
i want something hey yeah we gotta get a
cup dude
i'll start drinking for that this is
[ __ ] glass thing that's been sitting
there for years
how much of it do you think is mental or
do you think it's actually
it takes one shot i'm ready to go you
should dilute the solution and see if
it's mental get diluted dude honestly i
i'm i'm serious you should [ __ ] make
a dating app [ __ ] account for your
dad and you should bring some of this
[ __ ] jar of hennessy for us
we all have [ __ ] boaters in here why
not we all have bonuses because you're
jenga honestly i'd be like you need to
go to market with this [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
we need to have him here so we can
number one find him a girlfriend
because someone's watching and they're
they have a single mom right that's
right that's hot as [ __ ] yeah and then
and then we can hook them up
another one is we'll get drunk on his
moonshine and see if we get hard to see
if we sell that so the b plot i would
like to do
six dudes with boners
six boners
i think we're onto something i think
we're on something
[ __ ] the article like we're gonna do
straight up careful boys on this one
juices are kind of flowing today right
all right this is uh this is an episode
of careful boy another episode of
careful boys welcome back to careful
boys the world needs to know we're gonna
find bart's dad a death mate yeah it's
not a set it's not a soul mate right
it's a death
the last hours do you think that like
you you had a death mate like would you
really be thinking about the same
priorities as like a soulmate though
like a death mate i feel like i'd be
like i need somebody who's gonna like do
all the drugs with me getting crazy or
bucket list mate yeah bucket list oh i
like that what i mean yeah why does he
care if they have a house he's like i
don't want them to freeload off of me
they're not taking [ __ ] from you for
like you're gone i would assume though
that if you like legally you know
conjoin and then like they had debt
though suddenly it's like your family
assumes they're dead i could i could
understand those liabilities and
problems oh right yeah yeah yeah well
that's what i'm saying i don't think you
could pass on debt dude if you get
married it's both people's debts now oh
wait so like if she passes first then he
has to deal with that [ __ ] of the
passing i don't know but when you're
together
her debt is not your debt and if you try
to get a loan for something it affects
your credit score okay okay that means i
like the idea that when you sit down
with somebody when you're that age and
the first question is so do you have any
debt
i guess you have to think to yourself
for a second like hey this is going
pretty well if they want to know that
yeah yeah yeah because it's getting
serious it's not just a hookup
i guess they kind of like me or or
or is that just the new like hi how are
you
what if that's the beginning how high is
your debt cause you probably don't want
to waste time you want to go on a dinner
with somebody that you were like you
have like if i don't want my partner to
have debt i need to ask that off the top
yeah what do you mean what if i get it i
like you but you gotta just go all right
thank you very much
that's elder street
he got up really quick for moving like
that though
he got up quick he walks slow but he's
got a boner
[Laughter]
wait real talk uh how's your dad's
english it's weird
i got him like my dad got it got it got
it understood um so it's like a weird
it's not it doesn't sound like a
traditional asian accent and because he
learned english at a casino
it's like the words that he knows is
weird
[Laughter]
she knows sounds when he's happy he goes
like that
his eyes
[Laughter]
always wear sunglasses
plays he enjoys poker but he doesn't
like he's not like gangster at like yeah
like a poker shark but he likes playing
he plays a lot
but he worked 20 years ago how is he
with uh
modernizing technology like did he was
he one of those people that jumped on
like learning how to email quickly
uh is he in like stocks how i taught him
how to use his computer to check his
emails because he needs it for like his
[ __ ] like retirement mutual fund [ __ ]
i had to write like literally put your
right hand on the mouse
and move to the right i'll let you see
when there's a folder click that two
times yeah so it's like ikea directions
yeah i had to
i had to do that for my dad back in the
day no he still liked that still like
that yeah he still liked that damn
that's crazy my dad was on the cutting
edge of all that [ __ ] really yeah your
dad's much younger than ours how old is
your dad your dad's language was like
also in english right
my dad's 70 70 something else okay my
dad's like 68 years old oh okay yeah
same idea but no he was just really into
all that [ __ ] super into tech loves like
that's true because my stepdad's like
late 80s and he got my mom into uh tech
today's video is brought to you by
blenders
fresh from san diego california
the only sunglasses imma ever wear ever
again
it's called blenders eyewear baby and
you're going to be just as hooked
as much as i am once you see how cool
these bad boys are so shout out to
blenders for sending me a sample to play
with and i really love them and the
amount of quality that they're able to
have for the price is pretty amazing and
they're extremely trendy like they got
the polarized ones you know the ones you
can't see the eyeballs oh that's perfect
so you can like spy and see what the
hell is going on and it looks like an
orange mirror then they got tortoise the
one with the look brown and
tan specks almost like a cheetah print
yeah so that's my favorite very trendy
and they got traditional wireframe ones
they have all kinds of them and they fit
and feel awesome you know i like to use
it because i'm always at the beach as
you can see
and um some people think sunglasses are
meant to block the sun but it's also
meant to make sure that nobody's
drowning in the water and the sun
doesn't mess up your eyes but it's also
meant to look at your future wife who is
looking really good in a bikini yeah so
you know these sunglasses are dope
because chase fisher the person who
started blenders he used to be a surf
instructor and he was selling these
sunglasses out of his backpack on
pacific beach his goal was to create
adventurous just like our lifestyle
mid-priced eyewear just like our
lifestyle we can't afford that crazy
stuff and he wanted to give options with
the cool same factors as all these other
leading super expensive styles and
unlike the big brand shades that you've
probably lost or smashed in the past
blenders are actually affordable and
that's why i like them so much because i
do got some like 200 300 shades but then
you want to baby them so you never end
up wearing them and what i like about
blenders the price allows you to wear
them all the time and because of the
price you're not going to cry as much
when the inevitable happens
and it's perfect for people like me too
because you know i go out there and i
adventure i mountain bike i do all this
stuff but i never wear my expensive
sunglasses for this reason and they only
stay in my car for driving and that's
not cool and with dope as blender has
in-house designers so they're always
coming out with new styles so they stay
up with the trends and you could
probably pick a pair of a design that
you already don't have they don't just
do sunglasses they also do prescription
glasses blu-ray blockers readers and
even snow glasses as well so to get 15
off your blender's purchase visit
blendereyewear.com and use the code off
the record vip that's off the record vip
use that code to get 15 off blender's
sunglasses blenderseyewear.com
get yourself a pair my dad's into it too
even though he's not good but my mom
never wanted to get to it so she sucks
at it completely which is what i was
asking but that also means that he's
probably never gonna go on like an
actual app or anything like that right
oh you know what he needs to do it all
in chinese because my mom was more into
that [ __ ] when it was inject like she
can read everything my guys didn't have
a cell phone dude my dad was old my dad
was burning cds like in the in the
that's dumb he was one of the first like
group of groups of people who were
buying those things and like because
they were a thousand dollars that's so
cool and he was trying to start like a
little uh
side pirate business does he have a 3d
printer too he doesn't have a 3d printer
now
he would have won that means you have to
run your dad's dating account you have
to run his bumble yeah well if anything
my follow-up question is like how how
does your like how does a old person
like your dad uh how is he going to go
about trying to find somebody old-school
with a newspaper oh whoa that's how he
was dating before yeah like literally
like hey i'm uh
i'm debt free
i own a house my son graduated college
like that kind of [ __ ] and then what a
romancer
like that would be his classifieds i
ain't got no problems yeah and he's
looking through i was like oh you like
oranges too i got an orange tree and
then like they start writing letters to
each other or talk on the phone or some
[ __ ] ryan does you is your dad still
with it within your life yeah yeah yeah
he is yeah yeah he's good with computers
he's good with porn have you seen your
dad's porn searches
that's a doozy
you've seen those porn searches yeah
yeah i have what what was like i've seen
a lot of weird [ __ ] because my dad
thinks my uh
i get i set up a computer i left my
facebook signed in yeah and then he was
using facebook thinking that that was
just facebook but it was my facebook so
you can see his history friends of mine
he thinks they're hot he likes it
well yeah because he's like because he's
like clicking on him and or sometimes
he'll just straight up send him to me
he'll send it to you white identity he's
like your friend's hot i'll just with no
explanation he'll send a friend of mine
i'll go okay i get it is your dad anyone
we might know no he's like 70 something
no that's pretty funny we might not
know i was talking we're talking with
tim and then tim says they have a family
chat right
in the family chat randomly his dad
posts wow look at this it's a picture of
jill working out or video geo working
out
and then tim's like why did you put this
in here and he was just like
[Laughter]
what if he meant to send it to one of
his boys
it's weird because my dad can see my
messages too and the mom's in that chat
the mom like he could see my private
[ __ ] uh dms on facebook wow so like
and i totally [ __ ] forgot because i
just let him do it i was like you know
he probably thinks it's entertaining and
then like throughout the years i'll be
like talking to chicks saying like nasty
[ __ ] and i just go oh [ __ ] i forgot my
dad could read all of this
and he's all hella proud yeah he's
probably
it's
does
a
good
reality show what if your dad's reading
it and he's like
just like when i was in high school
[Laughter]
i have one of those i definitely have
one of dads who just like well no matter
what i do like as far as girls he'll
always gloat that he was better or that
he had way more than you love it
gotta rub it in your face yeah he's one
of those guys like my girlfriend by the
time i was 20 he was like i had so many
more girlfriends than you by this age
like he was he from the philippines
though like is he was he there yeah
because i heard the the average out
there is like you have five girlfriends
yeah some [ __ ] like that you got a lot
of girlfriends i guess it was like i
don't know a seventies thing sixties
thing well
i feel like in the philippines the
averages have like four wives that's
true like you just have a lot of
partners yeah or just have a lot of
possibilities i don't know possibilities
and he's disappointed in you because
you're trying to make sure i was like as
straight as possible i don't know what
it is oh but he was just he was very
like gloating about every single thing i
remember a junior in high school i was
on a i went on a road trip with my dad
my mom and i was sitting in the back
seat of the van and my dad is in the
front seat it was like at like nine
o'clock at night and we didn't really
talk much we weren't really close at
like having these types of conversations
about women you're in the backseat i'm
in the back seat and i'm like i'm like
angsty i'm like a junior my dad is like
he's looking at the the [ __ ] river
here at you and he goes hey nick uh
do you like
do you like talk to girls and stuff
and i'm like and the whole time i was
like mortified i was like dad yeah like
what are you talking about of course i
talked to girls dude
and he's just like maybe he thought you
were gay yeah he probably did he
probably like we all do
that's just because of evidence though
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah look at the
stuff i show you guys off camera that's
awesome
like when uh when you're in high school
there's that period of time where like
like call me sleep over whatever all the
time my dad would ask me like hey how
come it's always dudes that sleep over
and i'm like because they're homies
dad you want me to bring a chick over
and [ __ ] her in our house
what are you saying that's literally
what he thinks or dad if i was a girl
you would just let me go sleep at
another dude's house right now no way
why you guys have all these male
sleepovers the [ __ ] is wrong with you
with all these dudes if i were your age
i'd be trying to get girls to sleep over
and it's like i'm 13. exactly
but maybe
maybe it's also when they like
you know you have a bunch of dudes sleep
over and then you think you're being
slick but then they check the computer
and they're like these [ __ ]
were looking at porno the whole time
yeah i'm talking about
maybe we didn't learn about browsing
history yet they're just like
these [ __ ]
yeah that i'm sure that was definitely a
thing my dad probably thought i was into
some weird [ __ ] because he caught me
looking at the wrong porn one time like
i was just [ __ ]
around like when you go to like remember
like old school like rotten.com yeah
like [ __ ] like that where it was like
just it's just to be shocked it wasn't
to [ __ ] jack up big bugs [ __ ]
chips or something like lemon party he
was like he was like asking me he was
asking if the new printer was like good
and i was like oh yeah i could just
print it prints out so great let me show
you and then i forgot one of my tabs was
open and i wasn't i didn't even remember
what was on it but it was like a [ __ ]
girl and she was like she was like
bondaged with the american flag oh [ __ ]
whoa and she was all like cut up and
then my dad was like
that's what was coming out of the
printer no that's what was on the screen
that would have been crazy
that would have been there's a printer
yeah let me show you
it's funny if it prints slow and he's oh
american flag
oh no not my welcome to america
porn not my patriotism stuff what a
genre what did you did he talk to you
like oh my god i think because it's
[ __ ] asian daddy's not gonna address
it he's just gonna feel weird yeah yeah
yeah never talk about it ever again
i had more sex talks with my mom than my
dad same
my mom just told me
don't jack off too much
because it's not good for you wow i
never had boy was she wrong dude yeah i
know
i still
i will still think that um japanese
people are different from like regular
asians that's true because we're more
open about sex yeah we talked about
yeah because my niece the other day was
like man i'ma [ __ ] quit this school
[ __ ] and i'm gonna be a hooker and i was
like what the [ __ ] and then hannah was
like
yeah maybe maybe that's a good idea i'm
like no you don't [ __ ] tell her that
[ __ ] and then later i was like god damn
it
this is really my family and it's been
unleashed in her you're like at least
wait till you're 10 years old okay
jesus christ
that's true my dad talks to me about sex
it's like a giant gap
it's like there's just a lot of unspoken
things and he uses like euphemisms so
he'll be like hey you know like uh if
you can't get the job done i would just
pop a couple of oysters
and then you're like i think you're
talking about sex i think yeah you know
like he's talking about boners yeah he
never talks about oh when you're getting
a bet he doesn't even get even close
enough to like being in a bed with a
girl it's like he just dances around
like you can't get the job done my mom
straight up told me like um hey all
those girls that you've been bringing
over like
you shouldn't be buying hookers and i
was so offended because i was like we're
hooking up dude like they actually like
me for me i'm not [ __ ] buying hookers
they go to my school mom
exactly
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
first of all i want to bring a hooker to
her to the house
they're from
homeroom she's like okay why is there a
guy standing outside every time
that's my buddy steve man i was like
i was like why did you go straight i'm
like your son
your son has the ability to talk to
women and and and romance them i didn't
buy this what the [ __ ] why does she have
goldfish in her heels
you know what her reasoning was what the
way they dress and it's just like
probably abg of like late 90s yeah she
was just the best she's like oh they
dress like a hooker so i'm assuming that
they're hookers because their mom
wouldn't let them dress that way yeah
and i'm like you have no sense of
[ __ ] fashion my dad didn't want me to
date this girl because she looked like
he goes this is his warning he goes
don't date her she has homeboys homeboys
because she look like like a typical
like i guess like
yeah but you're like dad i'm one of them
no because i really my dream my dream
like when i entered high school was to
date one of the girls like that looked
like she was on those party flyers yeah
with the blonde hair and the streaks and
stuff and then i did and then i [ __ ]
found out uh we were cousins oh yeah
that's a twist did you guys i've been
there
man in that order or
do you guys have any have any physical
interactions yeah not not all the way
but it's the filipino [ __ ] curse
where like
that's why filipinos don't tend to date
in the community first cousin no no it
was like through marriage but it's bad
enough to get [ __ ] roasted by
everybody because they all fell
well at least it's no jon snow move
at least you didn't [ __ ] her first like
what happened to me
what is this real thing i got her
pregnant
i'm against abortion so what am i gonna
do well that's all we'll say cause this
is [ __ ] careful
[Music]
you